the cold war saw two sides face off in
an ideological battle for the future
in europe and north america the conflict
is often discussed as being between nato
and the warsaw pact
but nato predates the warsaw pact by six
years and during that six years
something interesting happened the ussr
asked to join
which raises a pretty obvious question
why why did the ussr want to join nato
so in the four years prior to the
establishment of nato the ussr and the
western powers had a pretty rocky
relationship
the west was extremely concerned with
the red army given that it was
absolutely massive and there were
worries in washington that the ussr may
start conquering territory piecemeal and
pick off the western countries one by
one
as such the western powers founded nato
the north atlantic treaty organization
to protect themselves from any potential
threats in the future
now officially this was a simple
defensive alliance that anyone in europe
could be a member of and wasn't aimed
specifically at any one nation
unofficially though it was the communist
scary club now the soviets weren't silly
and its leadership was at this point
filled with pretty shrewd diplomats who
knew what nato really was
and when stalin opted to follow in
lenin's footsteps and die there was a
chance for the ussr's foreign policy to
pivot
two people important to this were
lavrenty beria and viator slav molotov
who came up with an interesting idea
let's make friends with the west this
plan involved several steps
the first was the reunification of
germany on the condition that had become
a perpetually neutral state
in return for what was essentially the
ussr giving up east germany the leaders
of which were not consulted the soviet
union wanted to join the new european
defense community which as the name
suggests didn't include any
non-europeans
obviously the western powers would never
go along with this and so when it was
rejected to make it look like they were
conceding something the soviets offered
to join nato
this offer was semi-serious in that the
soviet leadership expected it to be
rejected but prepared for the
eventuality that the western leadership
would get very drunk or something and
say yes
so why did they apply to join well the
answer is simple
it was a win-win if the western powers
rejected soviet membership then they
were admitting that nato was in fact an
anti-soviet bloc which would in turn
allow the ussr to build its own alliance
and give it much greater free reign in
its foreign policy
if the western powers accepted soviet
membership the nato's character as an
anti-soviet alliance would change into a
general european defensive one and also
germany would stay forever disarmed
which given recent events was something
that the ussr very much wanted
as you'll be aware the answer from the
west was a no not for want of churchill
trying and the no was for the exact same
reasons that the ussr wanted to join
however they weren't so open about the
exact reason why and cited the ussr's
non-democratic government and occupation
of eastern european nations for the
negative response
and so the ussr was now free to act in
retaliation and did so by forming its
own alliance in 1955 and thus
the warsaw pact was born i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker rob
waterhouse moe
marvin cassell aaron the white jordan
longley james castaneda gustav swann
jerry landon
maggie patzkowski copper tone rasheed
ali winston caywood misses it
spinning three plates lexi schwinn
matthew shipley anthony beckett robert
wetzel
marcus arsenault corso wolf spencer
lightfoot and charles the first